for top-level sports people it's not
just skill and athleticism they count so
often it's mind over matter
psychology is now seen as increasingly
vital to women having a sports
psychologist is just as valuable as a
strength and conditioning coach in elite
sport the difference between success and
failure is often the finest of margins
it's all about raising the bar one year
to the next
the annual boat race between Oxford and
Cambridge universities as one of the
oldest and most prestigious events in
the sporting calendar moving out to
nearly half a length it's very
encouraging for Cambridge for the
competitors it's 20 minutes of pure pain
but also pure pressure when they walk
out for that boathouse there will be a
hundred thousand people standing on the
back that is something you just can't
get your head around until you've
actually lived it how the rowers cope
with that intense pressure can make the
difference between glory and failure
the Cambridge women's team have won the
last two races and this woman has been
one of the secrets of the success I work
on managing their thinking knowing that
they are in control of their
psychological state sports psychologist
Helen Davis has worked on specific
techniques to help the team at the most
mentally testing moments in the race
when the pain kicks in they have trigger
words that they've planned for in
advance that they will say to themselves
to get across the finish line as
training for the 2019 race intensifies
just trying to keep up with teammates is
mentally grueling trying to make those
crews is huge pressure I get off the
water and I've just been trying to keep
up with people who compete at World
Championships and then I work on my PhD
and I'm trying to keep up with people
that I feel are so much smarter than me
so it's pressure that I put on myself so
I will very much encourage them to view
pressure as a challenge focus on certain
things with their thinking that's going
to help them with their performance
rather than focusing on the
uncertainties of their situation
[Music]
understanding what makes athletes cope
or panic at those crucial moments is an
ever-growing obsession in professional
sport it's the multi-billion dollar
question that sports psychologists are
constantly trying to answer
dr. Jamie Barker lectures at the world's
leading sports science university lufs
brat in Britain what is the reaction
that individuals go through and how does
that contribute to how they perform
that's the intrigue that we have ok in
Jones if you just try to relax as much
as you can in 2013 Jamie helped devise a
cardiovascular test it compared the
physiological reactions of athletes who
thrive in a high-pressure situation with
those who flop a group of aspiring
professional cricketers were set a
specific target we had a scenario where
they would have to score 36 runs of 30
deliveries when facing a bowling machine
the cricketers were warned that their
results would be made public and would
decide who makes the team and who
doesn't
sharp so what's the only kind of turn
nearly half the players hit the test for
six and scored the runs and most of them
went into what psychologists call a
challenge state with a challenge state
my body releases adrenaline which opens
up my arteries which means there's blood
glucose and oxygen going around my body
I'm able to make better decisions I'm
able to move quickly over half the
batsman found themselves on a stickier
wicket and fail to make the runs they
knew slit enters the so-called threat
state in a threat state I experienced
the release of cortisol which constricts
the arteries around my heart is there's
less blood going around my body and
hence my performance may suffer there's
a sports psychologist we can then start
to go in and say how can we help you to
go from a threat state to a challenge
state Jamie employs a mental
visualization technique the sports
psychologists have used with a variety
of professional teams athletes are asked
a picture a set of scales on one side of
their demands the obstacles to success
they're taught to tip the balance the
other way towards their resources the
attributes they possess that can help
them it is about trying to develop a
perception of control but can
individuals really focus on the things
that they can influence rather than
worrying about external factors
[Music]
sports psychology is sometimes
criticized as a phony science but many
major sports teams and personalities now
use psychologists and there's a growing
acceptance that this boosts performances
in sports as in the world beyond a
mental edge can bring a winning one
everyone on this team pushes themselves
to incredible limits and that's why
they've come so far academically and in
sports